[Applause]
you're on Dancing with the Stars like
why didn't you want to do that show cuz
in our minds like in my mind I'm like
why I've done shows we've done radio
shows together to where I'm like I've
seen you dancin I'm like you you dance
well thank you I appreciate it well the
reason why I'm on Dancing with the Stars
is because when I was in fifth harmony I
got made fun of a lot by like online
bullies saying patrols saying that like
oh she can't dance they were laughing at
me they were calling me the weakest
dancer they were like oh she's so
embarrassed think you wanted to kind of
prove to everybody exactly cuz that
really hurt my confidence like I would
walk around and be like man super
insecure and thinking when I'm
performing oh my gosh is that person
judging me in the audience if they think
I look stupid do I look stupid but I
know that I had it inside me and this
show has given me the opportunity and
that platform to to prove something only
to those people but to myself and this
is a beautiful opportunity and platform
to use this and say hey if anybody who's
watching right now anybody in the
audience if you've ever felt scared of
something because you were bullied or
made fun of you can go for it like I
hope that I can be a voice I know I said
it on the show but I hope that I can be
a voice or an inspiration for someone
who wants to reach their dreams or go
for sure and here's the
[Applause]
failure and lifelike I think failure is
only when you don't try like because
we're not always gonna win it's not a
little meet your day your moment but
like at least you try they um deep would
you do dance with the Stars you know
what you do it you know I can kick I'm
coachable I'm coachable I'm strong I
think I can pick girls up you know your
wife is like what in the context of
dancing I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this